[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Chris Sims the former NFL
quarterback and of course pro football
talk live co-host if I would have told
you five years ago
Carson Wentz may be on his way out of
football you would have said what my I'd
go wow I mean what what happened what
how serious was his injury that he had
that that would make him want to retire
at this point of his career that's what
I would have thought you know I don't
think he's going to be out of football
Dan but I'd certainly think he's
officially relegated to back up
quarterback that's for sure yeah uh yeah
and and again now you know that's I
understand it but let's not forget too
it's this year the last game it was not
good I get that you know he was the
quarterback of a team earlier this year
who couldn't protect or run the ball at
all Taylor heinecke kind of got to get
the benefits of when the team got
together uh but you know he he was okay
last year it was 27 touchdowns and seven
interceptions last year it's not the
worst guy in football he just makes some
dumb mistakes but I don't I think his
starting days are done Dan all right let
me ask you about the bills in Bengals in
the aftermath if you're a player on the
Buffalo Bills right right now
how much do you want to have this game
rescheduled
or make it a tie
I don't I don't want it rescheduled I
don't like I I I think I'd want
if I was a player or even as I sit here
right now I just want to go let's just
move on with life and continue to go
forward here
it just the karma throwing us back out
there on the field this week or even
maybe next week where that's been thrown
out there as well to me you're just
gonna reignite the bad thoughts and the
feelings and all the the mental health
issues that could go along with this to
where hey this is just it's an
unforeseen circumstance what about the
Bengals I I know I you know I it stinks
life's not fair sometimes and
I that's just the way it felt I don't
know it's I'm sorry I I do feel for them
I understand that I feel for the Ravens
and the fact that they don't get a
chance or maybe the bills could have
beat the Bengals and then the Ravens
could have beat the Bengals and they
could win you know the division and have
a home playoff game but it's just the
way it's you know shook out this year
and I it's unfortunate certainly because
the Bangles are really good but you know
one thing I know about the Bengals they
don't give a damn that's for sure they
got a quarterback I think who goes okay
wait whatever it doesn't matter eff it
if we gotta go play on the road and beat
Josh Allen and Mahomes there we can do
it bring it on and I think they'll be
just fine yeah I wonder if
what do you do if you're the NFL because
if Buffalo says we don't want to go back
to Cincinnati yeah you can't you can't
hand them a forfeit it'll look bad
you know
the court of public opinion would be
really really upset with the NFL but I
don't know can you do winning percentage
when it comes to the seating for the
playoffs yeah I I feel like that's to me
the best option now that that that's the
way I feel about it at least uh you're I
mean it's it's not going to be fair but
I think that's really as we look at it
right now you know it's either hey we go
on this week and we push forward and we
play the week 18 slate and the bills and
Bengals played one less game than
everybody else and we just got to figure
it out or it's wait we make everybody
else not play football right yeah for a
week and we finish that game yeah uh or
vice versa they finish week 18 and then
they finish that game the week after to
me that just causes more problems and
issues than it's worth and I think you
just gotta go forward when you got
injured and uh you lost your spleen take
me back to what the the Medical well
like I don't know if you knew how badly
you were you know hurt right it was
different than you know Monday night and
I'm not trying to make the comparison
other than the medical facilities and
the attention that were on the field
that day when you got injured yeah well
I think the NFL has gotten even better
in that department as compared to my day
right now that's what 16 years ago
basically but you know it was kind of a
controversial thing there because again
I was somebody that yeah this it wasn't
as as jarring as what we saw here the
other night but you know they brought my
wife in to say bye to me
um and and because they weren't sure
wait like wait when did they like they
brought my wife in right before I was
gonna go into surgery and all that to
say bye to me because I had lost nine
pints of blood right and you only got 14
in your body and they were already
starting the blood transfusion at that
point
um but yeah it was it was is very iffy
wow um and and I had a ton of blood in
my abdomen and I did they didn't know so
you know again I can relate to a degree
uh this was was far more serious and
immediate right at the moment but the
medical attention was phenomenal it's
the hard it was the hard part you know
and we talk about this a lot it's just
that I was a grown man I didn't think I
was dying on the field I wasn't sure
what was wrong with me I was extremely
uncomfortable but you were dying I was
dying right I was I was bleeding out
internally and that's why I was I was
short I couldn't figure out why am I why
can't I breathe as the game was getting
to the end like I couldn't because I had
so much blood trapped in my abdomen
there was no room for my lungs to expand
um this was certainly a more harsh
reality check here and hit home
especially because we saw it on the
Marquee game maybe of the year on Monday
Night Football but the medical staff
couldn't have been better and they some
of them took some heat because I
continued to play and all that and it
wasn't fair they did everything they
could within their power and it was a
weird injury and it was unforeseen at
that time and you know still hasn't been
seen to this point to this day and
you're taught to hide the injury
right well I we were all in two
I'm a Sims so I'm already a stubborn SOB
all right and I was I'm I haven't
established myself as a definite you
know franchise quarterback right Dan
yeah I mean I there's they were gonna
wait you're gonna have to pull me off
the field that just wasn't gonna happen
and that's the struggle that you know
the NFL and players have to this day all
right if you're Jim Harbaugh
feels like there's more than just smoke
here if the NFL calls I'd say Carolina
offers Jim Harbaugh the job
what do you do
I think he'll take it that's the first
thing and I brought his name up you know
in conjunction with the Broncos last
week a little with Florio on PFT just
because I've heard from too many people
around football the yeah that think he's
he's trying to get back into the NFL
that's his ultimate goal I understand
like the appeal I mean he's one of the
safer bets out there I think him Sean
Payton are probably the safest bet as
far as like you know you need a guy
that's stable proven tried true will
come in change the culture get things
going in the right direction yeah he he
makes sense for that and I can see that
why a Denver or a Carolina would like a
guy like Jim Harbaugh I don't see Sean
Payton and Carolina feels like and and
it feels like Sean Payton is going to
have his pick of whatever job therefore
I want to know what's the best
quarterbacking situation that I'm going
to go into would that be where you know
Harbaugh and Sean Payton would probably
go who's your quarterback going to be
Carolina doesn't have one unless you say
hey the Reclamation project of Sam
darnold okay
you don't have a high draft pick I think
you have eighth where is Denver you
don't have any draft picks and you got
your quarterback there uh right Arizona
maybe if that's open you got Cliff
Kingsbury if you're all in on that uh
the Colts good team no quarterback right
handicapped jobs there if uh you're Sean
Payton or Jim Harbaugh right you know
the the the cliff Kingsbury thing's
interesting I think when all said and
done they'll stay status quo because of
the Kyler Murray injury and it seems
like there is guarantees in Cliff
Kingsbury's contract through 2026 right
so I think that'll save him at the end
of the day
um and and then the other three you know
you you said it right I think the thing
though that's interesting about Jim
Harbaugh is I don't think quarterback is
a Make It or Break It type of thing for
him he's he's not going to make the team
about that we know what they're going to
do it's going to be some boring offense
that's going to be detailed and tough
and the defense is going to be detailed
and tough and they're going to tackle
you and block you and and play
situational football the right way
that's what you're going to get from Jim
Harbaugh
um Sean Payton yeah I would think is a
little bit more quarterback thinking
that way you know and and Denver's the
one that jumps out to you when you you
certainly think about that situation
because it is that an enviable job I
know that's the question who would have
thought if I would say Hey you get to
coach Russell Wilson in Denver
and that might be a negative I am yes
that that's the thing we don't know is
what are his thoughts and feel of
Russell Wilson I mean I think everybody
knows Russell Wilson's good and we
expect them to turn it around I think
there was you know again the league
itself I think Seattle was always
telling people hey there's he's good but
he might not be as great as you think
and I think a lot of people thought oh
maybe they're just saying that to for
propaganda purposes and all of that uh
but how could you not think that by
watching that this year uh but the the
that and let me just say this about the
Carolina Panthers too I think that
team's got a lot of young Talent it's
just a quarterback situation so it's
yeah is it the dysfunction can you fix
the Broncos and that quarterback because
the team has a lot of things you like or
do you go with wait we got a team in
Carolina in Indianapolis who have some
potential but the quarterback is still a
major issue and has to be fixed there I
guess this is a good problem for the
Giants to have but I I brought it up in
September if they play well if they go
to the playoffs now what do you do with
Daniel Jones and saquon Barkley
because you got to make big Financial
commitments I'll make you the owner of
the Giants what are you going to do with
those two players now that you're
playoff bound I'm I'm gonna keep them
for sure I've been saying that with the
Daniel Jones situation here for a little
bit one I mean franchise or are you
going to give them a long you know big
deal I'm gonna give them a I'm going to
give them a deal I'm gonna give them a
deal that's like you know maybe a three
four year deal that I can get out of
after a year or two maybe two years to
be safe that way what if he says no
well I I would go well tell me where the
grass is greener and tell me who's going
to believe in you more than we are he
could go to Washington he could go to
Carolina well he could but he got do
they have Brian dabal and and you know
do they believe in them the way Brian
Day ball and the maras do you believe do
you believe in Daniel Jones I do believe
okay if I say he's gonna cost you 40
million dollars a year
do you believe in Daniel Jones yeah I
mean listen that's about where I think
you should be that didn't sound defense
I can deal well I mean again the number
all right that's it's a big number well
then what do you do with saquon Barkley
can I get saquon Barkley four years 40
million dollars I don't that would be
dicey that's a scarier situation and
he's the one that maybe I would think
about franchise okay all right all right
so that that'd be the one I would think
about Daniel Jones though as I've said
and I think I've said to you before you
know it there's a lot of positives there
really is and and to say that he was
with a bad offensive line the first few
years of his career is really an
understatement it was the worst
offensive line and there's still not a
lot of talent around him and you're
seeing a coach that kind of just put him
in the right spot polished a few things
with his game and all of a sudden every
week we go I mean Daniel Jones and say
what Barkley are carrying the offense
you see them play yeah it's quarterback
design Runners hand it's a sake one it's
bootleg it's oh my gosh I don't have a
lot of time to throw it I gotta get it
out my hand quick on a drop back pass he
does that well he scrambles well so I
want to see the consistency you know you
got a good head coach now get him a
couple of weapons there before I let you
go right you want to talk about the
elephant in the room
what is that elephant
you're Feud with ESPN well I listen I
just don't like they cherry-picked I got
no problem with them putting me on blast
but I made a comment off of Von Miller
talking with
um you know Michael Parsons a few weeks
ago right with the Jalen hurts and the
Philadelphia Eagle situation and Michael
Parsons kind of saying hey it's the team
and I said yeah I said Jalen hurts is
really good I said they would still be
really good with Gardner minshu like I I
still think they would be in the the
conversation for one of the best teams
in the NFC of Gardner minchu was the
quarterback does that mean they're as
good with him as Jalen hurts no but my
problem with it Dan is okay they marched
the ball up and down the field against
the Cowboys he plays really good he
throws two interceptions which one of
them you go no receiver you can't let
the DB take it out of your hands and
take the ball and then the fun they
fumble the ball twice they're up by 10
in the fourth quarter but where was ESPN
SportsCenter then they didn't want to
tweet anything hey Chris Maybe you were
freaking right with that comment well
they instead they're gonna wait till the
team knows apart they don't do that all
right and why would they put you on
SportsCenter you worked for NBC well why
would they put me on their Instagram
then and try to get all these likes and
clicks and attention off of them well
they want so all I'm saying is Buck Up
Bart and then bring me on and talk or
give me credit the first week okay why
don't you show up it's not that long a
drive from Stanford Connecticut up to
Bristol and then orlovsky walks in the
door you say hey we're going in together
to do NFL live I would love that I'd
love Dan so I'm all for and I am nothing
personal to Dan I'm more about Omar who
runs the Instagram there who I used to
work with at Bleacher Reports
we're supposed to be friends so that's
where I didn't like that I have no
problem I know I'm wrong sometimes I get
that I'm not I have to make a comments
and opinions about every subject in
football so I'm gonna be wrong I
understand that and I'd still have great
respect for Jalen hurts all I was saying
is I didn't think he deserved to be in
the MVP conversation with my home but
why don't you have them on Pro why don't
you have Omar on pro football talk live
Dan you work there you know how
SportsCenter and ESPN is they don't let
any of their employees talk to anybody
ever I mean so
I I can't deal with it so I'm not the
kind of guy that's just gonna sit back
and just let them slap me around you
know me well enough now so I attacked
them a little bit and you know but it's
nothing personal to any other on-air
talent I just thought that was cherry
picking and a little bit of a BS move
that they did there ESPN's got some
spleenin to do
yes they do full circle there with the
spleen well done that's why they pay you
the big bucks wait you got Omar coming
there my
that's the sounds of the ESPN hallway
yeah that's what it sounds like when
Omar walks down the hall
could you take orlovsky
I don't know I don't know okay I don't
know I got I I listen I I like listening
to Dan he's awesome with what he does I
like to think I could take anybody I
mean that's the way I am I mean geez
unless he's unless he's like a defensive
tackle or an offensive lineman you can't
take you can't take booger and you can't
take swagu no definitely not how many
times you can't take me to times no way
I don't want to mess with her either
you're right those are the real moments
you gotta have though like you know how
those those fathers always talk to their
kids and like how a kid always thinks oh
my dad can beat up anybody I can
remember like my kid being like five
years old six years old and him seeing
some football players I played with and
them going him going well Dad you could
still beat him up right and I went nope
absolutely not he'd kick the crap out of
me Phillip I got no chance and I thought
that was a good teaching moment to go
you know sometimes you know you can't
win them all you just gotta learn
good to talk to your songs always always
say hi to those keep jerks back there
[Laughter]
on your side wait are you guys on sims's
side or Omar's see
yes yeah more Omar
we're simsish oh you're Sims ish yeah
good always Chris I take that back
you're not jerks I do like no you know
I'm on Omar's side because she's
creating content and that's his job all
right well I'm doing the same here too
and one thing we do know is I could take
you and I know where you are so you
better watch it all right but if I get
you after you've been at the dispensary
uh then yeah then I can take you that'll
tilt the scale for sure I can take you a
little bit thank you bud all right all
right guys we'll take a break play of
the day up next